j'ouvre notre second débat vous le savez
le plus souvent possible il est
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour il est consacré ce soir au bras de
fer entre les États-Unis et l'Europe
pour attirer les plus grands projets
mondiaux de décarbonation notamment
c'est
usines géantes de production de batterie
électrique on parle de giga Factory au
mois d'août le président américain a
dégainé un plan climat et anti-inflation
appelé Highway pour inflation réduction
Act loi protectionniste qui a déjà
attiré plusieurs grandes entreprises
européennes sur le sol américain driver
c'était peut-être la première victoire
politique de Joe Biden le 7 août 2022
après 18 mois de négociations et une
nuit de débat marathon le Sénat
américain adopte son ambitieux plan pour
le climat la santé et la fiscalité son
nom l'inflation réduction Act son
montant 400 milliards de dollars
je suis convaincu que cette loi restera
comme l'un des exploits législatifs les
plus marquants du 21e siècle notre
projet de loi réduit l'inflation crée
des millions d'emplois bien rémunérés et
constitue le paquet climatique le plus
audacieux de l'histoire des États-Unis
les États-Unis veulent réduire
drastiquement leurs émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et pour cela ils vont
subventionner les produits verts mais
surtout américains 7500 dollars pour
l'achat d'un véhicule électrique neuf
aide à l'installation de panneaux
solaires aide aux entreprises
américaines pour la production dans
l'éolien le solaire l'hydrogène et les
batteries si elles sont mais d'une
America des mesures que certains jugent
protectionnistes pour Joe Biden c'est
aussi un moyen de contrer son rival
chinois
nous fabriquons des choses ici en
Amérique et nous les exporterons à
l'étranger plutôt que d'exporter des
emplois à l'étranger comme nous l'avons
fait pendant beaucoup trop longtemps une
guerre économique que l'Europe voit d'un
très mauvais œil elle craque avec ses
aides les investisseurs quittent
l'Europe au profit des États-Unis
il y a un risque aujourd'hui qui est là
et qu'on doit se dire entre amis ce
risque c'est que les États-Unis
d'Amérique regardent d'abord les
États-Unis d'Amérique ce qui est normal
nous faisons pareil avec nous regarde
ensuite sa rivalité avec la Chine
et en quelque sorte que l'Europe est
donc la France devient une sorte de
variable d'ajustement pour empêcher cela
des négociations sont en cours les
subventions pourraient être élargies à
certains produits européens
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Sylvie Metelli bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes économiste directrice adjointe
de l'Institut de relation internationale
et stratégique et auteur de ce livre
géopolitique de l'économie 40 fiches
pour comprendre le monde elles sont
illustrées ces fiches et le sens aux
éditions et Olivier le 26 bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes associés
chez pwcratégie membre du comité
d'orientation de la fabrique de
l'industrie ancien conseiller industrie
à la présidente de la République c'était
à l'époque de François Hollande et vous
étiez également délégué au territoire de
l'industrie auprès de du ministre de
l'économie et des finances dans les
années 2019-20
Christine kardella bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes rédactrice en chef des
pages idées et des bas chez nos
confrères des échos Mathilde Sirault
évidemment est resté à mes côtés donc ce
cette loi cette inflation réduction axe
c367 milliards de dollars pour les
entreprises qui investissent dans les
technologies vertes sur le territoire
américain ainsi que pour les ménages
achetant des produits verts fabriqués
aux États-Unis et ça c'est important si
l'immatelli si on prend un peu de de
recul si on dézoome dans l'histoire
économique américaine c'est une rupture
alors c'est une rupture avec la période
récente mais jusqu'à la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale les États-Unis
n'étaient pas un pays convaincu que le
libre-échange était finalement la
meilleure des solutions et c'est une
rupture dans un contexte assez
particulier dans un contexte où ce pays
s'engage comme nous tous et ça c'est
important en ligne réductionnax ça porte
le nom de DIM flychen mais en fait c'est
une blague pour le climat et on n'a pas
on a choisi de pas mettre le mot climat
parce que ça fait pas l'unanimité aux
États-Unis vous se rappeler des proches
de Donald Trump et des républicains sur
ces sujets là alors que l'inflation
était beaucoup plus vendeur donc je
ferme la parenthèse donc c'est une loi
pour aller vers la neutralité carbone ce
qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle on va
quand même pas le reprocher aux
États-Unis et c'est aussi une loi vous
avez parlé des plus de 300 milliards
d'aide pour pas faire la transition il y
a aussi 300 milliardaires au ménage pour
l'achat de médicaments pour faire
baisser les prix des médicaments c'est
une loi aussi qui prévoit des
augmentations d'impôts sur les grandes
fortunes sur les entreprises pour
financer cette inflation réduction donc
c'est aussi une loi qui va qui essaye de
renforcer la démocratie américaine et je
crois que quand on le voit dans cette
perspective là c'est vrai qu'on est dans
un changement de ton dans un changement
de régime mais probablement de
perspective pour la mondialisation mais
malgré tout il n'y a pas que du mauvais
dans cette loi il y a pas que on avait
prévu de le dire mais c'est très bien de
le dire dès le début du débat il a été
annoncé au lieu d'un mi-août cette loi
elle a été annoncée par Joe Biden on l'a
vu tout à l'heure notamment dans les
titres
les effets on s'est rencontré déjà dans
une autre émission sur sur la chaîne
économie bismart et vous disiez que les
effets se font déjà sentir c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des grandes entreprises
européennes qui qui ont cédé aussi reine
de ce de ces subventions américaines
c'est ça indéniablement c'est une loi et
fait rapide ce qui peut nous surprendre
parce qu'on aura pour on a plutôt
l'habitude des lois et des textes à
effet long et la liste des entreprises
qui ont déclaré
changé de priorité et donc faire des
investissements qu'ils avaient prévu
notamment en Europe et les faire aux
États-Unis était la fois longue et
prestigieuse il y a alors il y a des
projets un peu emblématiques d'un volts
l'entreprise scandinaves qui va donc se
relocaliser aux États-Unis
on a aussi Volkswagen qui va faire la
même chose quand même l'entreprise
emblématique du secteur automobile
allemand qui a indiqué on a la mise en
pause du projet de Tesla à Berlin qui va
se faire là-bas on a une liste de grands
grands projets extrêmement plus
important c'est la partie émergée de
l'isberg parce que on parle beaucoup des
grands projets c'est à coup de milliard
on les voit mais comme c'est un guichet
je dirais aux pourcentage de fabrication
il y a aussi plein d'entreprises plus
petites qui sont en train de se poser la
question mais ce que vous nous annoncez
sont des décisions qui sont prises ou on
peut encore les faire changer d'avis
c'est c'est grandes entreprises alors si
on prend un certain nombre de projets
que j'ai énoncé ils étaient déjà les
décisions étaient déjà prises pour
l'Europe et puis elles ont changé donc
il faudrait les faire revenir en arrière
on verra certainement ce sujet là que si
on avait au moins une réciprocité par
rapport à ce dispositif qui était mis en
place au niveau européen on pourrait
avoir une chance de leur faire changer
d'avis je participais à une table ronde
récemment avec le directeur général de
Vercors qui est en train de faire une
une gigafactory de batterie dans le nord
de la France et il annonçait clairement
que lui depuis 18 mois attendait
toujours les engagements des autorités
publiques pour subventionner à un niveau
comparable son usine son concurrent
Norfolk il avait il suffit de quatre
mois pour qu'il ait la lettre
d'engagement de sa subvention donc il va
falloir qu'on fasse quelque chose
quantitatif puis aussi qualitatif en
termes de rapidité d'agilité d'exécution
évidemment détailler la réponse
européenne un peu plus tard dans ce
débat Chris qu'est-ce que vous retenez
vous plutôt l'aspect finalement positif
les États-Unis prennent un virage
écologique qu'on pouvait attendre ou
alors cette espèce de coup bas à
l'économie européenne pour moi c'est
vraiment un coup bas l'économie
européenne c'est c'est une machine à
détruire l'industrie européenne c'est
vraiment il y a vraiment je te pense une
menace existentielle sur notre industrie
parce que au moment où l'énergie est
beaucoup plus chère en Europe on est
allé deux à quatre fois plus cher en
Europe à cause de la guerre d'Ukraine et
qu'on le fait qu'on était obligé de
faire venir du GNL que le gaz russe
n'arrive plus comme avant etc donc au
moment où on est affaibli par ça alors
que les États-Unis eux sont sont
tranquilles un point de vue énergie et
bien on nous met un coup supplémentaire
avec cette I a ou enfin Biden profite
d'une certaine manière de la faiblesse
de l'Europe pour assigner le coup de
grâce quoi pour moi c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un coup de grâce alors on va
l'écouter tiens Joe Biden au moment où
il promulgue la loi pour le climat et
contre l'inflation je suis sur le point
de promulguer l'inflation Redemption
acte l'une des lois les plus importantes
de notre histoire permettez-moi de le
dire d'emblée avec cette loi le peuple
américain a gagné et les intérêts
particuliers ont perdu et donc dans
cette loi on a un peu évoqué il y a
jusqu'à par exemple 7500 dollars de
crédit d'impôt pour les ménages
américains qui achètent une voiture
électrique à condition qu'elle sorte
d'une usine américaine batterie comprise
il faut aller jusqu'au bout de la phrase
parce que elle est importante donc là on
a beaucoup parlé de l'Europe mais
finalement cinématiques est-ce que c'est
pas d'abord en pensant à la Chine et à
l'avance prise par les les industrie
automobile chinoises en matière de de
voitures électriques que Joe Biden pense
et je pense que que c'est sur ce coup là
que cette loi est probablement la plus
dangereuse alors c'est vrai je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit c'est un coup de c'est un coup de
massue qui est donné aux Européens mais
ce qu'en fait le coup de Matthieu était
déjà donné depuis la guerre en Ukraine
avec les prix de l'énergie très
clairement les prix de l'énergie et au
fond avec l'inflation réduction Act Joe
Biden garantit quasiment 10 ans
d'approvisionnement sûr et certain
d'énergie à un tarif donné c'est autour
de 30 dollars le le
exactement donc on est on est vraiment
sur quelque chose avec lequel on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas lutter alors pour une
raison il faut bien il faut bien y
penser pour une raison aussi c'est qu'on
est très en retard sur la politique
énergétique européenne et en particulier
sur le développement des renouvelables
et qui est-ce qui a bloqué pendant très
longtemps moi je me souviens il y a une
quinzaine d'années on travaillait sur un
projet de communauté européenne de
l'énergie se sont avant tout les
Allemands qui bloquaient parce qu'au
fond c'était tellement pratique
d'acheter du gaz russe pas très cher
qu'on n'y est pas allé donc faut se
regarder un petit peu et regarder sur
quoi on n'a pas avancé je pense qu'on va
en parler ensuite alors pour répondre à
votre question ce que je trouve beaucoup
plus dangereux à long terme parce que là
finalement on a peut-être moins
d'instruments pour lutter en gros si
l'Europe se réveille aujourd'hui aimer
face aux défis de cette inflation avec
du championnat les mesures nécessaires
et les moyens nécessaires l'Europe est
un gros marché on peut s'en sortir j'ai
dit si mais c'est jouable c'est faisable
et je pense qu'il y a une prise de
conscience et que ça devrait ça devrait
ça devrait avancer mais par contre sur
la Chine on est quand même dans une
logique de fragmentation de la
mondialisation avec une mondialisation
sur laquelle ou une partie une moitié de
mondialisation sur laquelle les
États-Unis nous diront ben vous marchez
où on travaille plus avec vous ou on
continue à vous à vous rentrer dedans
avec nos réglementations etc etc et sur
ce point là on va voir ce qui va se
passer la semaine prochaine avec les
déplacements européens en Chine français
de Madame V mais je pense que sur ce
point là on a vraiment besoin d'ailleurs
pour bien comprendre par nos interrompre
c'est c'est les États-Unis qui vont nous
obliger à choisir notre camp c'est ça
d'une aux Etats-Unis qui vont nous
obliger à choisir notre camp qui vont
nous obliger à rentrer dans le rang en
fonction de leurs intérêts américains
très clairement et puis c'est surtout
au-delà des États-Unis c'est aussi les
États-Unis qui vont nous demander de ne
plus commercer de ne plus faire
d'affaires avec la Chine et là on voit
toutes les conséquences que ça peut
avoir bien évidemment je reviens sur la
la stratégie américaine liée à cette à
cette loi à cette une flèche réduction
actes avec cette citation ce témoignage
c'était dans un article de votre
quotidien des échos qui étaient
passionnants ça se disait comme un roman
qui racontait l'histoire de cette de
cette loi et et dans cet article donc il
y a la citation de l'ancien ministre de
l'Économie et commissaire européen
Thierry Breton voilà s'il raconte nous
avons appris qu'une grande entreprise
dans le domaine du retraitement avait
été approché par l'administration
américaine qui lui proposait de financer
pas le cas 70% de son investissement de
garantir 10 ans de débouchés lui être
sûr et on en a parlé un contrat de
fourniture d'énergie à long terme 4 à 5
fois moins cher qu'en Europe Olivier 26
vous avez travaillé à l'Elysée et à
Bercy est-ce que ce sont des méthodes
comme ça
à ce point offensive ou agressif est-ce
que c'est c'est normal ou est-ce que
c'est totalement nouveau ce que vous
avez déjà vu ça à ce niveau là non dans
tous les cas il va falloir peut remonter
peut-être avant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale mais je n'ai pas cette
historique là donc je mets dans les
années dans les années mais dans les
années récentes ça c'est pas vu à ce
niveau là donc on a là une forme qui a
été qualifiée de très agressif par le
Président de la République on peut
traduire ça en protectionniste on sait
très bien que la première cible c'est
effectivement le commerce et le rapport
de force avec la Chine très bien que
c'est un moyen de réindustrialiser des
États-Unis qui était en retard comme une
partie de l'Europe pas toute l'Europe
mais une partie de l'Europe et donc et
en plus c'était quelque chose qui était
consensuel entre les deux politiques
mais clairement je dirais la l'Europe et
la variable d'ajustement comme ça a été
dit et nous allons prendre très cher ça
a été dit tout à l'heure entre une
énergie qui est plus chère une
subvention qui va jusqu'à 40% de
d'investissement mais c'est rarissime
des subventions qui vont jusqu'à 40 % de
l'investissement j'ai travaillé pour une
compagnie française Saint-Gobain dans
les pays d'Europe centrale et orientale
avec des fonds européens clairement on
arrivait rarement à ces niveaux là donc
on est sur quelque chose qui est
extrêmement agressif protectionniste
sans doute et qu'on retrouve aussi dans
d'autres compartiments du jeu américain
litard pour les objets qui sont duos
entre le civil et le militaire il y a
une liste de produits pharmaceutiques
que les États-Unis veulent faire sur
leur territoire qui est sorti quelques
mois après le covid nous n'avons pas
l'équivalent en France on peut rajouter
des exercices d'intelligence économique
etc etc la loi chips aussi sur les semis
conducteurs exactement donc on est quand
même face à un état un allié économique
politique militaire qui s'est doté sur
tous ces compartiments de jeu
économiques de dispositifs pour je
dirais protéger ou en tous les cas
permettre à son industrie de se refaire
c'est systémique et qui fait du
démarchage
et ça c'est nouveau vous parlez de la
faiblesse de l'Europe sur ce sujet
notamment qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire
on voit bien qu'il y a une tentative de
répliquer ce plan au niveau européen
c'est compliqué il y a aussi la
tentative de négocier des fameuses
exemptions avec les Américains alors ça
peut être efficace le plan je vous
demandais pas répondre parce qu'on va en
parler plus tard mais sur les exemptions
c'est vrai que on peut tient d'ailleurs
récupérer une autre citation de de
Thierry Breton qui qui nous dit alors
attendez je vais retrouver ça qu'il a
négocié
la voilà on a on a créé une tasse force
au niveau entre la Maison Blanche et la
Communauté européenne on a listé 9
problèmes nous avons envoyé une lettre
d'injonction avec des points très précis
qui sont de notre avis contraire aux
règles l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce ou bien ils vont les régler ou
bien il faudra envisager des mesures de
rétorsion pour l'instant il y a rien
pour l'instant il y a rien
du tout acté c'est une demande de
l'Europe mais c'est une négociation mais
ça n'a pas été acté mais on pourrait
répondre à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure comment on pourrait faire
puisque nous aussi on peut donner 350
400 milliards mais on le fait de manière
beaucoup moins simple et de manière
beaucoup moins rapide hier moins rapide
parce que on sait qu'un plan d'intérêt
européen un plan important d'interope
les fameux pieds c'est deux ans
d'instruction du dossier donc Emmanuel
Macron a demandé que ce qu'on a et qu'on
fasse quatre mois mais les Américains
c'est c'est tout de suite c'est à dire
vous avez effectivement comme le disait
Olivier tout à l'heure votre papier en
quelques en quelques semaines et de la
même manière c'est plus simple parce que
quand vous ouvrez une usine et bien
alors nous c'est plutôt des aides pour
pour l'investissement mais eux c'est la
subvention vient en crédit d'impôt dès
que vous commencez à produire donc vous
êtes sûr comme ça de produire afin de
faire des bénéfices en fait dès le
départ puisque vous avez vos crédits
d'impôts dès le début il faut peut-être
raconter quelque chose Olivier le 26 et
c'est parce que là on vous dit l'Europe
arrive essaie de négocier des
dérogations etc sauf que cette loi
américaine a été très compliquée pour
Joe Biden à obtenir sa séjour à une voix
près il y a un sénateur qui j'ai vu ça
dans les échos qui qui détenaient le
destin de cette loi qui s'appelle Joe
machin ça s'invente pas enfin bon donc
on imagine mal Biden revenir en arrière
sur une vous voyez ce que je veux dire
sur une loi qui a été aussi compliqué à
négocier quoi je veux dire c'est c'est
une loi aussi qui rentre dans son cycle
électoral elle a une portée politique
qui est évidente il a réussi à avoir un
accord enfin dans ces cas-là on voit la
complexité de ce que ça peut être une
chambre qui est divisée entre plusieurs
composantes vous allez pas pour des
intérêts qui sont externes à votre
nation à votre politique intérieure
allez remodifier l'équilibre à la
rigueur peut-être on obtiendra quelque
chose sur des voitures ou des batteries
qui seraient faites peut-être je dis
bien
serait fait en Europe et qui pourrait
rentrer dans le crédit d'impôt mais
surtout ce qui est des subventions à
l'investissement sur l'outil productif
ça paraît totalement inimaginable et ce
n'est pas moi qui le dis c'est le
commissaire européen qui est en charge
de la négociation avec les États-Unis
donc il ne faut pas se leurrer sur cette
capacité qu'on pourra avoir à amender
ses toits aujourd'hui si on le minimum
est peut-être sans utiliser des mesures
protectionnistes mais au minimum il
faudrait qu'on mette en place une
réciprocité notre industrie est agressée
il faut qu'on y réponde Christine cardan
à quel niveau se sont fait les
démarchage et action les les présidents
les DG des des groupes qui recevaient un
coup de fil j'essaye d'imaginer de de
conseiller de Joe Biden c'était moins
direct que ça mais c'est toutes les
équipes autour de Baden qui ont contacté
peu à peu les grands groupes non ça
c'est je sais que par exemple Bill Gates
je crois que c'était même dans le même
article que celui ou qu'elle faisait
allusion Bill Gates qui a contacté Jo
machin au moment où je Machin avait
changé d'avis sur ce texte si vous
voulez plus le voter et c'est Bill Gates
qui a pris son téléphone une première
fois et puis une deuxième fois et
lui-même a contacté en Europe des des
homologues donc billets c'est engagé
lui-même quoi c'est c'est je trouve
c'est assez phénoménal n'imagine pas des
patrons français appelés des patois
américains en disant venez en Europe
enfin
si vous pose une question
volontairement naïve ce sont nos alliés
les Américains pourquoi font-ils ça
c'est un vrai sujet c'est une question
qui avait posé Donald Trump en son temps
vous vous souvenez je crois que dans
tout ce qu'on vient de dire il y a deux
choses qui sont particulièrement
intéressantes la première c'est la loi
et la loi vous avez raison elle est
passée elle est passée de justesse elle
a des elle a des enjeux qui sont
considérables pour les États-Unis aussi
donc faut pas on pourra rien faire
contre cette loi maintenant il faut se
mettre en ordre de bataille et sortir de
vous savez on parle souvent de l'Europe
comme les herbivore dans un monde de
carnivores je pense qu'il faut sortir un
petit peu de cette idée là et se mettre
en ordre de marche alors on a ça veut
dire par nos interrompre on a été naïf
là on l'a pas vu venir cette fois
on n'a pas voulu utiliser si vous voulez
les les mesures qui sont prévues dans
cette loi sont des mesures qui sont à
l'opposé de tout ce qu'on a pu faire et
de tout ce sur quoi en étant engagé en
particulier à l'OMC depuis des décennies
et je pense qu'on a on n'a pas encore on
se sent pas encore le le courage de
donner un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière en Europe de se dire le
monde a changé la mondialisation telle
qu'on l'a connu c'est terminé chacun des
Français billes pas que les États-Unis
d'ailleurs la Chine et les pays du Sud
etc etc il faut que nous aussi on se
protège il y a ça il y a le fait qu'on
est à 27 et qu'on n'est pas tous
d'accord sur ce qu'il faut faire donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a assoupli le
mécanisme d'aide d'État parce qu'au fond
débloquer des fonds ça allait prendre
beaucoup de temps et puis après il y a
un deuxième élément et moi je trouve
contrairement à ce que vous disiez je
trouve que les États-Unis ont toujours
pratiqué ainsi c'est-à-dire aux
États-Unis quand vous quand vous
circulez un petit peu à Washington vous
vous rendez compte que tout le monde se
connaît que tout le monde se parle il y
a vraiment les patrons qui par le
politique etc et que faire de
l'influence si l'économie est un aspect
est un instrument de pôle la politique
étrangère et donc tous les moyens sont
bons pour défendre les intérêts de
politique étrangère des États-Unis
l'itar ça existe depuis 50 ans
rappelez-vous en 1900
les les conflits d'intérêts et les le
l'engagement de politique dans des
affaires économiques rappelez-vous
l'affaire Alstom il y a pas qu'en France
qu'il y a eu ce type de procédure où la
conformité juridique c'est aussi une
arme économique américaine c'est une
réalité les sanctions seuls les
Américains appliquent autant de
sanctions
de manière uniquement unilatérale donc
toutes ces choses là ont toujours existé
et c'est là dessus peut-être qu'on est
un peu naïf européen
contre l'IRA est passé a fait un tweet
pour dire bravo aux États-Unis enfin ils
viennent sur les sur le climat c'est
bien etc sans voir du tout le deuxième
niveau c'est-à-dire que l'Europe a dû se
prendre dans la vraiment dans la figure
et un autre argument aussi pour
compléter ce que vous disiez pourquoi
l'Europe le fait pas spontanément le
même genre de choses parce qu'on est un
grand marché de consommation le rhum et
pas un grand marché de production c'est
à dire qu'on cherche pas on protège le
consommateur d'abord le l'Union
européenne a toujours cherché à protéger
le consommateur et non pas protéger les
producteurs ou en tout cas à aider les
producteurs à bien produire en Europe
effectivement et je peux juste un mot
c'est super important ce qu'on vient de
dire parce que quelque part quand vous
protégez le producteur bah à un moment
donné il faut quelqu'un paye soit le
citoyen soit le consommateur et donc
dans leeflation réduction activaille
avoir un coût aussi pour la société
américaine alors qu'ils arriveront
peut-être à faire payer au plus riche en
tout cas c'est l'ambition de Joe Biden
peut-être pas mais à un moment donné il
va y avoir un coup la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est est-ce que les
Européens sont prêts à payer ce coût et
je crois qu'il faut commencer pour faire
accepter des réactions il faut commencer
à travailler à faire de la pédagogie
alors les craintes pour l'économie
française elles sont réelles c'était au
mois de novembre la première ministre
évaluée le manque à gagner à 10
milliards d'euros d'investissement et
10000 créations potentielles d'emploi et
donc évidemment Mathilde le gouvernement
des paris Stains et notamment le mise de
l'économie on va se concentrer sur la
réaction de Bruno Le Maire oui c'est un
combat effectivement que mène le
ministre de l'économie de façon un peu
souterraine pas forcément très
médiatique depuis plusieurs mois Bruno
Le Maire était dans les bagages
d'Emmanuel Macron tout début décembre
lors de sa visite d'État à Washington
alors à ce moment là bien sûr on s'est
beaucoup plus concentré sur le président
qui qui était à la maison blanche avec
Joe Biden qui a multiplié les rencontres
mais dans l'ombre le patron de Bercy a
mené tout un tas de consultations
stratégiques avec la secrétaire
américaine au trésors le conseiller
économique de Joe Biden notamment
notamment sur ce plan de subvention il a
piloté la fameuse task force sur les
discussions techniques le ministre être
amené la bataille politique pour en
quelque sorte convaincre ses
interlocuteurs américains que les
États-Unis avaient intérêt en réalité à
ce que l'industrie européenne elle-même
soit plus forte il appelait des la cause
des Européens et essayer d'harmoniser le
mieux possible les politiques pour
éviter une course au subventions il
fallait aussi dissuader en en parler les
entreprises françaises qui sont engagées
dans ce domaine de la décarbonation pour
ne pas qu'elle parte investir aux
États-Unis plutôt qu'en Europe il est
ensuite retourné à Washington Bruno Le
Maire c'était début février cette
fois-ci avec son homologue allemand on
l'écoute
nous sommes la Washington avec mon ami
Robert abbec pour défendre les intérêts
de l'industrie européenne et pour
assurer une concurrence équitable entre
l'industrie européenne et l'industrie
américaine nous sommes convaincus avec
Robert abbek qu'il y a de la place pour
une industrie verte européenne forte une
industrie verte américaine forte
il y a aussi une explication politique
on va dire à cette activisme oui
évidemment parce que on l'a dit les les
résultats à peine à se concrétiser de
cette activité
parfois le vice-président ou le
vice-premier ministre et depuis six ans
qu'il est en poste à Bercy il a en
réalité beaucoup voyagé il a multiplié
évidemment sa participation dans des
sommets internationaux alors par
penchant naturel d'abord on rappelle que
Bruno Le Maire maîtrise la culture les
codes de la diplomatie pour avoir
travaillé aux côtés de Dominique de
Villepin au Quai d'Orsay il a aussi été
brièvement secrétaire d'État aux
Affaires européennes mais aussi Thomas
par intérêt et ambition personnelle
Bruno Le Maire fait partie des
présidentielles pour 2027 en tout cas du
côté du camp du président et le ministre
soigne ses réseaux il ne compte pas
forcément rester à Bercy durant tout ce
mandat et sa conquête de l'Elysée
pourrait passer par une autre étape
celle de la direction générale du FMI et
le poste doit justement être renouvelé
l'année prochaine à suivre donc je
voudrais qu'on va on va vraiment parler
du plan européen qui a été dévoilé il y
a une quinzaine de jours mais peut-être
sur l'aspect français Olivier loinsi il
y a le plan 2030 je crois que c'est 54
milliards d'euros je dis ça de mémoire
déployant 5 ans pour notre et la moitié
pour la décarbonation est-ce que ça peut
servir à retenir les les entreprises
françaises qui seraient tentées par
l'inflation Act alors oui enfin c'est
fait pour aussi hein il y a une partie
de ce plan qui est qui est consacrée aux
investissements productifs il y a tout
de même deux limites qui je pense appel
à avoir une autre réaction que celle qui
est actuellement en place et qui
s'appelle France 2030 la première c'est
que c'est un plan qui est surtout
orienté vers les nouvelles technologies
celle de rupture et donc c'est bien de
financer l'innovation mais là on parle
de capacité de production donc
l'innovation et la recherche c'est super
mais il y a un deuxième aspect dans la
vie industrie une fois qu'on a innové
une fois qu'on a fait une rupture c'est
qu'il faut des usines en capacité pour
produire et ça c'est pas prévu
directement dans les priorités de France
2030 et puis il y a un deuxième aspect
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure c'est que
l'IRA c'est un mécanisme automatique
vous faites tel production vous avez le
droit à tel subvention c'est encore une
fois automatique vous êtes un
investisseur ou vous êtes quelqu'un qui
veut construire une usine aux États-Unis
vous prenez la règle vous multipliez par
rapport à votre production estimée et
vous savez exactement quel subvention
vous avez allez vous pouvez aller
chercher le financement et encore une
fois vous avez une sécurité sur la
subvention que vous allez aller voilà en
France c'est un système d'appel à projet
alors ce que j'appelle c'est un petit
peu caricatural mais des concours de
beauté et donc à ce moment là vous savez
pas si vous allez gagner ou pas alors il
y a des jurys ils sont extrêmement
pointus etc des fois ils le sont
peut-être un peu trop mais donc on a on
a deux mécanismes on a deux freins un
qui est plutôt sur l'innovation la
recherche l'autre qui est sur l'outil
productif l'un qui est automatique
l'autre qui se rappelle à projet mais
aux États-Unis ça veut dire que quelques
isacèvent pas tous les projets il y a
quand même un tamis j'imagine quoi il y
a un débat qui est en train de s'ouvrir
aux États-Unis c'est peut-être cet acte
là va être sur souscrit et les 370
milliards de dollars qu'on évoquait tout
à l'heure où vous évoquez pourraient
devenir un milliard un milliard pardon
Amiens 1400 milliards ou des choses
comme ça tellement
donc c'est quand même ou alors il
pourrait être souscrit mais il y a il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui de de système
d'arrêt à ce dispositif alors
évoquer plusieurs fois on va enfin en
parler en détail la réplique européenne
qui a mis du temps à se décider cette
âme traduit qu'il doit vous êtes super
attendu ta main parce que dans ce débat
on a annoncé
on va parler évidemment de du plan
annoncé il y a 15 jours mais ça commence
bien avant et oui la première réplique
c'est depuis Davos le 17 janvier la
présidente de la Commission européenne
Ursula van derlayen dénonce alors je la
cite des tentatives agressives visant à
attirer les capacités industrielles de
l'Europe notamment celle liées aux
énergies propres et elle vise
particulièrement dans son discours la
Chine mais elle rappelle aussi les
inquiétudes suscités par le plan
d'investissement pour le climat
américain l'occasion aussi et bien
d'annoncer la stratégie européenne pour
garder ses industries vertes on l'écoute
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
estime que d'ici à 2030 la valeur du
marché des technologies d'énergie propre
fabriqués à grande échelle avoisinera
les 650 milliards de dollars par an soit
plus du triple d'aujourd'hui pour
prendre de l'avance dans cette course à
la concurrence nous devons continuer
d'investir dans le renforcement de notre
base industrielle et rendre l'Europe
plus propice aux investissements et à
l'innovation voilà donc résumé et bien
la logique de ce plan industriel qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du Pacte vert
européen l'objectif je la cite que
l'Europe soit le foyer des technologies
propres et de l'innovation industrielle
et surtout que les entreprises ne fuient
pas outre-Atlantique vaste ambition
quelles sont les grandes lignes de ce
plan alors trois priorités d'abord
mettre en place une nouvelle politique
industrielle ensuite assouplir un peu
plus les règles des aides d'État et
réaffecter les fonds européens existants
rentrent un petit peu dans le détail ça
aboutit vous l'avez dit le 16 mars avec
la commission qui a proposé un règlement
européen pour une industrie à zéro
émission nette elle propose par exemple
d'intensifier la production de
technologie propre dans l'Union
européenne on parle éolienne pompe à
chaleur panneau solaire hydrogène
renouvelable stockage du CO2 des
technologies qui seront soutenues
financièrement elles auront droit à des
aides mais il en sera aussi demandé de
localiser deux cinquième de leur
production dans l'Union européenne ça
reste toutefois une incitation pas une
obligation la règlement prévoit aussi et
bien d'accélérer les procédures
d'autorisation en donnant assez projet
de clintèque un statut prioritaire ça
permet de raccourcir les délais il
passerait de neuf à 12 mois contre 12 à
18 ans l'absence d'une telle désignation
et puis enfin et bien les étapes
pourront utiliser par exemple le fond
pour la relance le fond pour
l'innovation pour soutenir ses
industries il y a aussi un fond
souverain qui est à l'étude réclamée par
la France et l'Italie mais pour
l'instant l'Allemagne s'y oppose alors
est-ce que c'est une réponse efficace
pour lutter contre cette nouvelle
concurrence américaine et bien en tout
cas c'est clairement l'objectif écouter
Thierry Breton on l'a beaucoup lu dans
cette émission on va l'écouter c'est lui
qui a impulsé ce règlement
sur ce sujet depuis début septembre
c'est que évidemment
ceux-ci s'inscrit peut-être été accéléré
par la décision de l'administration au
Biden de mettre sur pieds sont fameuses
ailleurs
et on s'en souvient le 14 août parce
qu'évidemment il y a eu tout de suite un
certain nombre de entreprises qui ont
dit on est appelé on a des opportunités
et que fait l'Europe etc alors
maintenant que fait l'Europe est-ce que
ça sera efficace installer la question
de nombreux entreprises salut ces
améliorations d'autres appellent à aller
plus loin et puis il y a aussi ceux qui
craignent un règlement très trop
protectionniste qui va obliger à
utiliser des produits plus chers qui
fait grimper les prix de ces
technologies et peut se répercuter sur
les consommateurs maintenant et bien le
Parlement européen et les États membres
de Union européenne vont débattre du
projet avant qu'il n'est force de loi
encore quelques filtres et du temps
avant que tout cela entre en vigueur
voilà encore du temps alors qu'on en
manque c'est ce qu'on a bien compris
Christine kerdelan comment les
industriels européens reçoivent ces
mesures annoncées à 15 jours justement
on en a interrogé un certain nombre il
le reçoivent plutôt mal c'est à dire
qu'il résonne en disant oui c'est bien
joli tout ça c'est beaucoup d'argent mis
sur la table mais finalement ça va être
compliqué ça va être encore des usines à
gaz et il y en a un qui nous a dit
ils n'ont pas compris l'intérêt
fondamental de liaret qui est d'un
mécanisme simple et dès que vous avez
installé votre usine dès le premier jour
ce que j'ai tout à l'heure on vous on
vous donne des crédits d'impôts on va se
dire on vous finance dès le premier jour
vous êtes sûr de gagner de l'argent
alors qu'en France en Europe pardon il
faut il faut passer par des arcanes
diverses répondre à des tas de ce que ce
que dit tout à l'heure cette jeune femme
il faut il faut c'est extrêmement
compliqué et on n'est pas sûr d'y
arriver on n'a pas la simplicité on n'a
pas la rapidité on n'a pas cette culture
américaine qui fait bien les
investissements tout de suite et puis
Olivier aussi il y a aussi une
opportunité pour certaines entreprises
européennes qui sont peut-être pas très
bien installés sur le marché américain
qui se disent bon bah non seulement il y
a de l'argent à prendre mais en plus on
va pouvoir s'installer là-bas quoi sur
des groupes internationaux à base
européenne évidemment c'est une
opportunité aussi pour profiter d'un
investissement à bon compte aux
États-Unis ce qui explique toute la
difficulté aussi qu'on peut avoir en
Europe de trouver un consensus pour
monter quelque chose d'équivalent ou
pour réagir de manière de manière plus
violente ou plus directe que ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est un
peu dans les annonces on l'a vu
l'objectif de 40% de technologie verte
produites en Europe l'objectif de 40% de
transformation des métaux aujourd'hui
non pas donné lieu à un financement
européen fléchi là-dessus de manière
spécifique donc on reste je dirais au
mieux au milieu du gué on va attendre
cet été mais on aura perdu encore un an
et on voit bien derrière ça que le
consens européen sur ce type de mesure
est difficile à faire il y a des pays
qui ont plus à gagner de continuer à
commercer notamment avec les États-Unis
que de développer une base industrielle
en Europe il y en a d'autres c'est la
position de la France qui considère que
ça réindustrialisation est clé parce
qu'on est descendu très très bas au sein
de même de cette Europe entre les
acteurs privés le groupe foldsken a
déclaré que c'était une très belle
opportunité pour lui pour développer son
marché aux États-Unis donc dans les
désacteurs privés qui trouvent des
opportunités d'autres qui se mettent sur
la position de défensive cinématiques
pour mettre 400 milliards tout de suite
sur sur la table est-ce qu'il est-ce que
l'aurait l'Europe aurait dû forcément
emprunter et si oui à ce moment-là on
sait bien qu'il y a des désaccords sur
ce type de stratégie entre les les pays
européens les frugaux et les autres quoi
c'est ça et c'est véritablement la
question de comment on finance on a
parlé du on a parlé du fond souverain
alors faut plutôt parler d'un fond de
souveraineté parce que là on va on va
jamais arriver à convaincre les
Allemands l'idée c'était mais si on crée
un fond de souveraineté ou un fond
souverain au fond ce sont toujours les
mêmes qui vont en profiter qui vont
dépenser qui vont puiser dans la caisse
et puis au final on se retrouvera tous
endettés et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
Thierry Breton a rappelé que on ne quel
que soit les mesures comprendra on
endettera pas la Commission européenne
et on poursuivra pas comme on a fait
dans le plan de relance suite à la crise
du covid donc c'est clair que la
question du financement est
fondamentale et problématique en Europe
on n'est pas du tout d'accord et je
pense qu'on n'a pas pris non plus toute
la mesure des risques qui s'annoncent je
crois que les Français sur ce dossier là
sont particulièrement éclairés ont
particulièrement venu vu venir le danger
très tôt en Allemagne Monsieur le Maire
s'entend très très bien avec son
homologue le ministre de l'Économie et
de l'industrie vraisemblablement ça se
passe bien moins bien entre la Scholl
c'est Emmanuel Macron et le ministre de
l'industrie allemande et son chancelier
ne sont pas forcément tout à fait sur la
même ligne donc on voit que c'est très
très compliqué et quelque part pour
compléter ce que vous disiez sur les
industries l'industriel aujourd'hui qui
est en Europe il voit aussi la
fragmentation de la mondialisation il
voit aussi que le risque de travailler
avec la Chine s'amplifie au fur et à
mesure que l'affrontement avec les
États-Unis s'intensifient et il se dit
au fond bah si je regarde une carte du
monde bon je peux rester en Europe c'est
encore un grand marché c'est vrai mais
aux États-Unis j'ai le marché j'ai les
technologies j'ai un état qui est maître
et qui est mis après à mettre du cash
tout de suite sur la table bah le choix
est vite fait en réalité alors
effectivement vous m'offrez la
transition sur sur ce que Bruno Le Maire
a finalement appel une nouvelle
mondialisation on écoute le ministre de
l'économie c'est en novembre dernier ce
que chacun doit comprendre c'est que
nous avons basculé dans une nouvelle
mondialisation
la Chine a basculé depuis très longtemps
dans cette mondialisation avec des aides
d'État massives qui sont réservées
exclusivement à des produits chinois
les États-Unis viennent de basculer sous
nos yeux dans cette nouvelle
mondialisation
pour
développer leur capacités industrielles
sur le sol américain
il faut pas que l'Europe soit le dernier
des Mohicans
et nous devons défendre nos intérêts
industriels européens avec plus de
fermeté plus de force et plus de
rapidité Christine kardellans est-ce que
c'est une effectivement pour vous une
nouvelle monalisation peut-être une je
simplifie mais une aire de repli sur soi
continent par continent alors oui du
protectionnisme effectivement montant le
protectionnisme monte en puissance mais
là où il a raison effectivement c'est
que on reparle de politique industrielle
le mot politique industriel c'était un
gros mot c'était vraiment un gros mot
vous voyez pas le dire il y a que la
France qui disait ça et qui osait pas
trop le faire les Allemands le faisaient
sans le dire les Américains le faisaient
sans le dire mais maintenant on le dit
et donc effectivement
on est on est on est en train de changer
de monde quoi donc à la fois on a une
fragmentation du monde et ça te demande
à sourcer une fragmentation du monde
entre des zones qui vont commercer entre
elles ce qu'on appelle du frenchoring
c'est-à-dire on va on envoie sur les sur
les zones voisines ou le amical en
quelque sorte donc les États-Unis
commerce de moins en moins avec la Chine
la Chine de plus en plus avec sa zone en
Asie du Sud-Est etc et nous l'Europe
avec les États-Unis et peut-être pas
avec la Chine quoi et donc c'est une
espèce de de recentrage sur des zones
amicales quoi et c'est à faire une cale
c'est un grand mot mais les les c'est un
peu le aussi le résultat de la guerre en
Ukraine qui ne se fait prendre
conscience que finalement on n'avait pas
de de les Russes on croyait que voilà le
commerce elle est adoucir les mœurs
c'est que et que c'était une théorie ça
c'était une théorie pour ne pas faire la
guerre et en réalité c'est pas vrai quoi
le commerce n'empêche pas la guerre donc
on se replie sur ses amis et sur ces
zones
Olivier lentilles est-ce que est-ce que
ça veut dire que c'est une
démondialisation est-ce qu'on peut aller
jusque là ou pas alors le terme le terme
est un peu polémique mais on va mettre
en terme économique aujourd'hui le
commerce mondial augmente moins vite que
le PIB donc quelque part oui il y a une
forme de démondialisation ou de
ralentissement de la mondialisation qui
est qui est très qui est palpable qui
est une réalité et sans doute qui qui
s'étendra le nombre d'entreprises qui
sont en train de régionaliser dans le
sens continental leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement et très importantes
on appelle ça résilience on apprenne ça
sécurité d'approvisionnement etc il y a
un mouvement souterrain qu'on ne voit
pas encore parce que c'est pas annoncé
ça se fait comme le font les industriels
doucement progressivement prudemment
mais on a ce repli je dirais ou cette
réduction c'est une des chaînes ah c'est
une bonne nouvelle en terme logistique
en termes de de coût économiques et
écologique du transport c'est une bonne
nouvelle ah oui tout à fait tous les cas
on a ce mouvement là et puis d'un autre
côté on a cet aspiration on est dans une
période qui est assez qui est assez
paradoxale parce que d'un côté tout ce
qui sont les critères environnementaux
que ce soit le carbone la scie
circularité matière vont amener à
ramener la production plus proche du
marché et puis en même temps on a des
espèces de de guerre entre zones
économiques à travers des subventions
qui tendent à tirer d'un côté ou de
l'autre
un autre point là dessus c'est il y a
une situation spécifique on parle de
l'Europe et c'est la bonne échelle on
parle de rapport de force entre des
continents ou des ou la Chine mais la
situation française sur l'industrie est
spécifique je tiens à le rappeler on a
l'une des industries les plus faibles en
Europe avec 10 % du PIB qui est
manufacturier la moyenne européenne est
à 16 l'Allemagne est au-dessus de 20
l'Italie à 17 et dans ce contexte là
reporter simplement notre réponse de
réindustrialisation on va au-delà de
l'IRA sur un projet européen est une
erreur l'Europe peut se protéger peut
maintenir son industrie au niveau où
elle est il y a des efforts à faire on
le voit mais la France ne foirera pas
l'économie d'implant de
réindustrialisation propre pour remonter
au moins au niveau du peloton européen
ce qui est drôle ce paradoxe pour
boucler la boucle c'est que tout ce que
vous dites Olivier va contribuer à créer
de l'inflation c'est-à-dire le fait
qu'on fasse plus appel aux Chinois pour
pour fabriquer des objets que plutôt à
des Européens
tout ça va aller plutôt dans le sens
d'une augmentation de l'inflation pareil
aux États-Unis or là dont on parle
depuis le début c'est la flash and
reduction max n'a rien à voir avec c'est
exactement l'inverse et d'ailleurs les
beaucoup d'experts aux États-Unis disent
que on va plutôt augmenter l'inflation
que de la diminuer avec cet i il y a un
dernier thème dont je voudrais parler
parce que en préparant l'émission j'ai
vu que vous il y a la question des mines
et c'est intéressant parce qu'on parle
de souveraineté dans ce débat et donc
effectivement pour produire par exemple
des batteries il faut du lithium on a du
lithium dans le sol français est-ce
qu'on est prêt à ouvrir des mines et
est-ce qu'il y a une acceptation pour ça
je trouve que c'est une idée
intéressante ça c'est un vrai sujet
parce que c'est vrai et ça ça rejoint
moi je partage tout ce qui a été dit sur
la mondialisation et le fait qu'on
rentre dans une nouvelle phase de
mondialisation mais je ne peux peu
m'empêcher en tant qu'economiste
travaillant dans un institut de
géopolitique de regarder la dimension
géopolitique de ces choses là il y a
deux aspects qui sont qui sont quand
même qui me questionnent vraiment le
premier aspect c'est ceux qui vont être
laissés pour compte dans cette nouvelle
mondialisation et tous les conflits
toutes les conséquences géopolitiques
que vous allez avoir et puis laissez
pour compte à l'étranger dans le reste
du monde dans ce Sud global dont on
parle tant et puis les laisser pour
compte aussi et la façon dont on va être
appréhendés vont être acceptés toutes
ces toutes ces conséquences dans le plan
dont on a parlé de Madame vanderlayenne
il y a cette idée de relancer les mines
est-ce qu'on veut vraiment des mines à
côté de chez nous c'est une vraie
question une vraie question on y revient
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Sylvie Mathy je
vais rappeler le titre de votre livre
géopolitique de l'économie 40 fiches
illustrée pour comprendre le monde c'est
aux éditions héro
lles la fin de ce numéro de sens public
je vous dis à lundi et je vous donne
l'invité de la matinale comme de
tradition demain à 8h Oriane Mancini
reçoit Claude grange qui est médecin
praticien hospitalier spécialisé en
douleur chronique et en soi palliatifs
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]